abandoned for the last 53 years this
eerie whaling station stands remote
rusted but reclaimed by the wildlife it
once hunted to near extinction
welcome to gritvigan
[Music]
gridvigon was a working whaling station
on the british island of south georgia
located 1500 miles away from the foot of
argentina founded in 1904 the vacated
settlement was once the largest whaling
station in the area
over 60 years over 175
000 whales were killed on the island out
of which 9 million barrels of oil was
produced from the blubber meat and bone
the station closed in 1966
after the local whale populations were
decimated
but there is hope for the wildlife on
this island beyond gritfighten the
island as a whole is thought to be the
most important penguin and bird breeding
area in the world hosting over three
million penguins a year
and the whales are making a comeback
although their populations are thought
not to be fully recovered the waters are
now a vibrant whale sanctuary the island
stands as a testament to the natural
world's great gift to bounce back and
reclaim what was once theirs
[Music]
you